all right guys let's get into today's
episode it's a q a
which just means that my wife is going
to read me questions that you asked me
on twitter what's the first one you got
plana dc
asks what's happening on july 12th
well on july 12th you'll find out duh no
listen we're going to launch something
new on july 12th
uh i'm really excited about it my team
and i've been working very hard on it
for last few months
uh i think it's something that will be a
pretty big inflection point hopefully in
a lot of people's
lives but it's not going to be easy it's
going to require a lot of work
we're committed to doing the work but
we're going to need everyone else to uh
to help us as well
uh and so there should be more
information about that coming out
thursday this week so tomorrow if you're
listening to this the day that we
release this episode
um and we'll see what people think but
uh we're super excited about it and
has been spending a lot of time on it um
and so hopefully everyone else likes it
as well
uh this is a question from your wife
paulina what's happening on july 11th
wait really
[Laughter]
july 11th is my wedding anniversary i
can't believe that i just walked into
that
but uh you know sometimes you get got
and i just got guy
just wanted to make sure you don't
forget okay um question from brent kt
how will you prepare for the next time
mercury is in retrograde
i still don't really know what mercury
in retrograde means for those that
listen to the amanda goats uh
episode uh she was telling me all this
stuff about astrology
i kind of think astrology technical
analysis uh
religion it's like all basically the
same thing um but
i'm sure that it's very interesting i'm
sure that there is tons of information
that you could glean
from things like mercury and retrograde
not for me
but it's a cool thing i might start just
dropping it in random conversation with
uh people to see what they think and
also be able to signal out
or kind of uh identify who the weirdos
are so if i just naturally walking down
the street somebody walks up to me go
hey mercury in retrograde they're like
oh yeah and they start talking about
like okay
let me move on i think it's when like
you have technological
problems like things go wrong anyway
okay so jason
asks how can bitcoin advance without an
upheaval of the us government in a broad
sense
the burn it all down narrative is not
helpful to widespread adoption so how do
you walk this fine line
yeah look i think that bitcoin is doing
exactly what it was designed to do it's
becoming a global store of value
um and so that's going to take decades
right we're already 12
years in i think it's going to continue
for a while i don't necessarily think
that
we're going to see fiat currencies
disappear if you think about it you know
there's over a hundred currencies today
in the world some of them are really
good and really strong and some of them
are really really bad
right if you think about it uh the
bolivia are still exists it's a horrible
currency right
as a store of value but it still exists
they recently decided they're gonna take
six zeros off of the end of the numbers
of the currency
uh in order to make it kind of more
realistic and more usable by people
but that currency still exists and so
killing a currency is very very
difficult
um and so what's more likely to happen
is there's going to be coexistence of
many many currencies around the world
uh all of them will be digital whether
it's a digital dollar a digital euro
digital one
private currencies things like
facebook's uh dm
uh or things like bitcoin that are uh
kind of decentralized now i personally
believe that once all of those
uh currencies are digitized the
competition will move to the monetary
policy layer
uh and that's where bitcoin is superior
in my opinion uh the central bank
uh is independent and it's predictable
two key qualities of
uh a central bank and also not only
uh does it have this kind of digital
sound money principle where it's outside
of the system and nobody can create more
of it
but also it has kind of cracked into the
zeitgeist of an entire generation right
everybody who is below the age of 35 has
heard of bitcoin before it's
this global brand with billions of
people now aware of it and so
what you naturally get is the longer
something sticks around the lindy effect
the longer it sticks around
uh the more people trust it the more
likely it is that it won't go away
so i think bitcoin is kind of entered
into that phase uh and so
over time more and more people will
trust it more younger people will come
into more assets they'll put it into
bitcoin
and what you'll see is this global store
value will end up kind of increasing in
total market cap and eventually
what you'll find is that the
decentralized digital currency of
bitcoin in my opinion is going to be
bigger
than all of the fiat money combined now
it's going to take a long time we're
decades away from that happening
but what you're just simply seeing is
strong currencies will become weaker
and new currencies like bitcoin will end
up becoming stronger and grow over time
and that's kind of how cyclically
uh these currencies have worked over
time so it's just a natural evolution of
money as we've known it
um nogan beck asks considering america's
history of manufacturing consent for
action that serves the elite
and since power has historically never
peacefully conceded power
how do you view the risk of the powerful
tanking bitcoin by any means necessary
to protect
their control and defend the dollar the
great thing about
wealthy people is that they're
adversarial to something until they
learn how they can make money from it
and so that's what we're ultimately
seeing with bitcoin is for years and
years and years
wall street and regulators and countries
and
um all these other organizations were
very anti-bitcoin they took a very
adversarial stance
the second they figured out how they
could make money or they thought it was
big enough for them to make money or
that it wasn't going away and therefore
they could make money from it
they all jumped in and so now pretty
much every wall street bank has a
bitcoin strategy
there's tons and tons of corporations
there's regulatory frameworks that are
being used to regulate these businesses
and even there's a country in the world
that has now made it legal tender
and so that's ultimately how this works
is people are adversarial towards
something until they can figure out how
to make money from it
now folks have figured out across
various entities in our society that
they can make money from bitcoin and so
now they're one by one
capitulating and becoming fans of
bitcoin and i think that trend is only
going to continue over time and so this
whole kind of like a
boogie man on the horizon of oh one day
there's gonna be this clash
i actually think it's kind of an
anti-climatic type thing
we can always think about that we should
always be prepared for that but instead
what's more likely to happen is already
you're seeing
politicians in the united states become
sympathetic to bitcoin you're gonna
eventually see people rise to power
in the treasury or the federal reserve
or other types of regulatory bodies
they're going to be sympathetic to these
assets
and therefore you're going to get kind
of this uh slow evolution or adoption
and then eventually we're going to wake
up one day and like oh my god it was
adopted by everybody
and so it just kind of naturally happens
over time and that whole idea of like
slowly then suddenly i think
is pretty accurate ben faircloth
asks how do you quickly and efficiently
answer the question from someone who has
no idea
what bitcoin capital or bitcoin
lowercase
is answer the question in two minutes or
less and then send people to the best
place to get more context i find it very
challenging
the first thing i always tell people is
that marketers did not create bitcoin or
they wouldn't have named the two assets
the same name the capital b bitcoin is
the payment rail
similar to a visa a mastercard or some
other type of infrastructure
the lowercase b is the asset itself
more similar to the dollar or the euro
and so what you do is you need lowercase
b bitcoin to be sent between two parties
you have to use uppercase or capitalize
b
payment rails right so bitcoin is spent
on the bitcoin system
and that's exactly how we get kind of
two different assets with the same name
now where i send people always is the
bitcoin white paper it's
a couple of pages it's very easy to read
through you can sit down and have it
done in 20 30 minutes
and there's some parts that are super
technical but there's also some parts
that are
very very illuminating in terms of this
is what this was created to be
and so i think that if you understand
there's a payment system capital b
bitcoin there's an asset lowercase b
bitcoin and then there's the white paper
which has kind of an overview of both
that's the best way to get somebody
educated in a very short period of time
crypto mipto asks
how do you multitask and manage your
time you're into
everything at once and killing it
well i definitely think time is our most
valuable asset i talk about that quite
often
um and so what i essentially do is i
aspire to be
ultra efficient now if you ask me or you
ask my wife uh i probably spend too much
time
wasting on stupid things right i spent a
bunch of time on twitter
or other things that aren't necessarily
you know measurable
in terms of the positive impact but
there is a lot of ancillary benefits
from doing those types of things that
might not seem
so obvious in the short term now in the
things that do seem very obvious i
compartmentalize my time
so i know that let's say for example
monday from
time a to time b there's a block of time
where i have 30 minute meetings back to
back to back to back with every single
person on my team
and what i'm doing is i'm basically
level setting for the week here's what
we did last week here's what our
challenges are here's what's going well
and here's what we're going to do for
this week
and we should go through that in that
block of time that compartment of time
i then have content days for example so
on wednesday and thursday afternoons
from about one o'clock to five o'clock i
sit down and all i do is i focus on
output of content usually for the
podcast and so when i do that i'm
compartmentalizing it i know going into
wednesday and thursday afternoons
that's all i'm focused on and so by
compartmentalizing your time you can
become hyper efficient
but you also can plan out exactly when
you're gonna get everything done
and so when you start to think about how
much time we actually have
what you find is one people are super
inefficient but also two
people don't have a plan and therefore
don't get done what they need to
because they simply weren't prepared but
i'm a huge believer that if you plan
correctly you'll end up actually
accomplishing what you want and that's
the
strategy that i use and it's worked out
so far so i just kind of keep doubling
and tripling down on it and improving
that process but that's basically it
just compartmentalize your time and then
stick to a disciplined schedule
what's up guys bang bang i hope you're
enjoying this conversation but before we
go any further i want to quickly tell
you about today's sponsor
blockfy blockfi has got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
eight point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use their cryptocurrency
exchange and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
blockfy.com go check it out and let me
know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it
hassan asks what is the next country to
adopt
bitcoin as legal tender i have no clue
what the next one will be
um you know there's a bunch of theories
you could argue that somebody in let's
say the eastern part of the world
uh you could argue that it'd be a
nefarious country uh you could argue
that it could be a south or central
american country based on
kind of el salvador's action or you
could even argue that the united states
will be the next one they'll kind of
surprise us all and capitulate
and go in and embrace this i have no
clue but i think that what
you learn if you study kind of the great
investors over time
is that predicting the future is very
very difficult and so rather than spend
time or
as i would think waste time trying to
predict the future instead you're much
much better off just making sure that
you're prepared
for a whole different set of outcomes so
are you prepared if no country's
adopted are you prepared of one country
are you prepared for different regions
of the world to adopt it or are you
prepared for everyone to adopt it
and if you can put yourself in positions
to be prepared kind of for the upside
opportunities but also protected from
any sort of downside pressure or risk
then you're usually going to end up
being pretty
set from an investment standpoint or an
exposure standpoint it doesn't always
happen that way but that's
kind of probabilistically the way that
it works and so i don't spend a lot of
time thinking about who the next one's
going to be
i just wait for it to happen and then
once it happens i dive in really quickly
uh and try to understand as much as i
can about the nuance and detail of
who it is why are they doing this is it
good or bad reasons
uh and then what the impact is going to
be and so with el salvador that was a
great example
i think people very quickly wrap their
heads around why this country was doing
it what advantages the country had
around being dollarized versus having
their own currency
and then what that impact would be and i
think that'll happen at the same time
that countries two three four and five
uh come out and announce the same thing
matthew rohlman
asks what was your what was the biggest
thing you learned from your service in
the military
uh we all die uh it's kind of morbid to
talk about it that way but
i think that was the biggest uh lesson
that i took away from it was
i was a young kid i frankly was too
naive uh probably to understand the
risks and the dangers
uh of being in the military or being
deployed but what you get is you get the
constant reminder of death and
uh you get it through a whole bunch of
different ways but as soon as that kind
of level sets with you or
or you internalize it what you realize
again is that your most valuable asset
is time
and so if let's say the average uh kind
of
life expectancy in today's society is 78
79 80 years old somewhere in there
if i'm 33 years old i pretty much know
what the average amount of time i have
left is
and so while it may seem like a lot
basically i've already lived a third of
my life
right more than a third of my life and
so that really puts things in
perspective in terms of trying to wrap
your head around
what are you doing what are you trying
to accomplish and then how do you spend
your time and if you
are able to optimize the way that you
spend your time i think that you
actually live a much more fulfilling
life and so that's how i spend time
uh or kind of my focus is making sure
that i'm spending my time in a quality
way
but it all stems back to when i was 20
21 years old deployed to iraq
and some of the lessons that i learned
there andrew wertheim asks
with so much inbound how do you handle
turning down requests
saying no to offers startup pitch calls
partnerships sponsorships
investment opportunities etc those of
which don't fit your personal mission
uh i've gotten way better at this over
time but i'm still not great at it
i'm an ambitious person and therefore
when i'm presented with opportunities
my mind usually jumps to uh what could
happen if this worked
um and i've got to really kind of uh
struggle and remind myself
no that's not the right way to look at
it instead it's what am i trying to
accomplish and does this
fit into what my goals are or what my
mission is
and so when you're able to kind of
reframe it from that perspective it
becomes much easier to say no to things
that don't fit along with what you're
trying to accomplish
um but with that said i'm also not great
in terms of
uh kind of handling all of the inbounds
so one day i sat down and i thought
uh and looked at my phone and i said
what are all the ways that somebody can
communicate or does communicate with me
there's about 17 different mobile apps
on my phone
and so when i think through that that's
just a lot to handle right and it's not
all necessarily just
net inbound it's also kind of going back
and forth in conversation
and so what i've essentially done is
i've had to get very comfortable with
the idea
i'm not going to be able to answer
everybody i'm not going to be able to
handle every single situation
while i wish that i could and you know
i'm kind of apologetic for the fact that
i can't
also i have to remain focused on what am
i trying to accomplish and again the
quality of the time that i spend what am
i spending my time on if i'm just
sitting there for hours and hours a day
answering emails
that's probably not the best use of my
time and so you just have to get
very very comfortable with the idea that
you may be disappointing people or you
may be offending people even though you
don't mean to
it's just simply at some point there's a
trade-off between accomplishing what you
want versus always serving everybody
else
and you just got to find that balance
wherever you're comfortable um
crypto chris wants to know when will you
run for office
short answer never uh that sounds
horrendous
uh i really really like my life i'm
gonna keep my life the way that it is
uh the idea of being a politician is
uh frankly like nauseating to me uh one
of the things that i always uh kind of
go back to is this framework of
in the country today are you more likely
to have an impact
as a private citizen in either business
or investing
or as a politician my guess actually is
that you
can have more impact as a business
person or as an investor
than you can as a politician in the
current environment and so just from a
pure impact standpoint
uh being in the private market is going
to be much much more advantageous for
creating change or
or kind of making any sort of progress
than actually sitting inside of a
bureaucratic institution
and maybe that changes over time but
even if it did change i still
really am a big believer of uh kind of
that public spotlight and scrutiny and
the mudslinging that happens in politics
which is very antithetical to the way
that i want to live my life
uh and the way that i kind of think
about engaging with those around me in
terms of creating progress or any sort
of innovation and so
the private market is something that i'm
really interested in uh and it's kind of
where i'll stay forever
i really don't see that being an
attractive path of going in
and wearing a suit in time being a
politician speak for yourself i would
make a wonderful first lady
um rand milstein asks
when a bitcoin movie is gonna be made
who will play
satoshi i think you have to have nobody
play it
right i mean that's kind of the whole
beauty of it is if you're gonna have
satoshi you almost wanted to be a
mythical figure
you don't want it to be a man or a woman
you don't want it to be an individual or
a group you don't want it to be a white
person a black person or a green person
you don't want it to be from a certain
region of the world
you don't want it to be somebody that
has a specific
gender or sex or religion or any of this
like we are all satoshi and that is the
beauty of it
and when you start to understand the
power of bitcoin
and kind of the ethos behind it and why
this whole um as marty bent would call
like immaculate conception is so
uh beautiful what you start to realize
is that
if we did not have that kind of
immaculate conception
we actually may be in a different
position and so i think that
if you create some sort of media whether
it's a movie or something else
you almost want to play into that and
really make sure that you don't put any
sort of labels
or descriptions on satoshi you want it
to remain that mythical feature uh that
mythical
kind of person or group and so by having
nobody play satoshi i think that you'd
be able to accomplish that
all right and the final question which
is my favorite comes from
nifty pickle um anthony you always say
you aren't out for fame or money you
just want to be quote unquote happy
but what does that mean are you a
hedonist trying to maximize pleasure and
minimize pain
or would you say you're really
optimizing for something deeper like
meaning
if so what gives you meaning i wake up
every single day and i think to myself
what do i want to do today
and i'm very fortunate that i can do
that um but i
pretty much for the most part not every
single day but for most days
i then go do exactly what i want to do
that day
and i'm able to do that because i have
freedom in a whole bunch of different
ways of my life
and so to me that ultimately is what
brings happiness right
if you want to hang out with certain
people you can do that it makes you
happy
if you want to engage in certain acts
you can go do that it makes you happy
if you want to go waste your time doing
something you can go do that if you want
to go help people you can do that
if you want to just sit in bed all day
you can do that when you have that kind
of ultimate freedom
what it allows you to do is pursue the
things that will make you happy
and happiness can be both a short-term
and a long-term pursuit sometimes they
align sometimes they don't
right sometimes you wanna let's say that
you wanna lose weight over a long period
of time
but right now in the moment if i eat
this donut i'm gonna be really happy
we gotta start to balance that stuff but
ultimately happiness to me is being able
to do what you want
who with who you want when you want to
do it and i'm very fortunate that i get
to do that on a daily basis
uh and so if that ever changes i'll
change what i do there will be a day
where i just wake up one day and i say
i'm done with the internet uh i'm never
going to tweet again i'm never going to
write again i'm never going to create
content again
and when that day happens it just
happens like it's because my
preference has changed or the things
that i'm trying to accomplish change but
until that day happens i'm going to keep
doing this because i enjoy doing it
and there's really kind of no master
plan behind it just go one day at a time
what do you want to do today go do it
you'll be happy
amazing thank you so much i love how
polina selected many of the people's
questions based on their user names like
nifty pickle uh that was not lost on me
but listen i really appreciate everyone
listening today we'll have to do these q
a episodes more often
uh it would mean a ton to me make sure
that you're subscribed to the podcast
or if you're watching this on youtube
make sure you subscribe to the channel
or
go ahead and turn on notifications and
again tomorrow july
i think it'll be eighth maybe whatever
thursday is uh we will be announcing
what is going to happen
on july 12th so make sure you're tuned
in for that and i'll see everyone
very very soon